I'm green falcon
[Music]
clear
[Music]
huh do you hear that
[Music]
must have been nothing
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
now it's my turn to play
stop
[Music]
Carol
[Music]
I thought I killed you the first time
I promise I will not make the same
mistake twice
[Music]
you are a good time
but a lousy fighter
[Music]
smile
snap indeed
[Music]
Teague
you saved my life no Carol
you saved mine
[Music]
oh
that's just me
foreign
[Music]
partner take the scumbag downtown before
the Mexicans find him and blow his ass
away
keep you alive Chico
prende
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
hey
do you know what happened
no
oh I get it when I say no stuff blows up
cool
Amazing Earth from space
[Music]
yellow Falcon what do your senses tell
you stroke 2 is a killing machine
his armor is impervious to our Busters
you got any ideas red Falcon sure do
yellow Falcon Blue Falcon you remember
our battle at Dango Bluff I'll take the
legs you take the blasters it was Beaver
Creek and I took the legs make sure you
sharp that flank Black Falcon
um
are you talking to me because
I'm the green falcon no time for that
black falcon purple Falcon arm missiles
Roger that farming the phone now
uh battle formations we're going in hey
Roger hold up copy that crunchy my
Falcon is green hey hey hey we can talk
about our Falcon colors when we get back
to base Black Falcon right now we got a
mission to do fall into Falcon formation
well here's the issue is that you're
gonna give me an order I'm not gonna
know you're talking to me
I'm not in a Black Falcon come on chill
it out black falcon yeah Black Falcon
relax first of all I don't like the way
you guys are saying Black second of all
there is no Black Falcon I'm green
falcon black falcon homie no one's
trying to get up in your grill here
don't talk to me like that no don't say
Grill like that I'm the green falcon and
I oh stopping some Black Falcon about it
what the [ __ ] do you mean by that black
folk brother I understand what you're
going through do you no I don't think
you do how would you feel if I called
you red Falcon huh whoa and purple
Falcon how would you feel if I called
you yellow Falcon huh that's a racist
that was racist yeah that's racist oh
that is racist that's racist
oh see okay no forget it Black Falcon
out green falcon green falcon
hey why'd that green falcon fall out of
Falcon formation Black Falcon get on
that and report back
falcon
Black Falcon come in
give yourself up Carlo why would I do
that
when I have the ability
[Music]
give yourself up Carlo
and right here
or am I over here
foreign
enough of the games Carlo
the games are just beginning
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
mirror mirror all on the wall
who is the fairest
you are under arrest
for the murder of Mary Deeley Meg Foster
and one detective Mason Jimenez
Now where's the girl
oh Detective
you assume it's the real me standing in
front of you
but maybe that's just what I want you to
see
when in reality the real me
is safe in a hiding spot
okay that's the real you all right
or maybe I'm over here no no you're not
over there Carlo I'm only going to ask
you one more time where is the girl go
ahead and shoot Detective
I mean what do I care if you get seven
years bad Loca you know it's not safe to
keep a gun cocked like that even if you
are just pointing it in the mirror turn
around and put your hands on your head
now for that you really are going to
have to find the real man are you
kidding me
hmm
foreign
what why would you shoot a mirror Carlo
it's you I'm holding your lapel now
you're done it's over
you're gonna cut your hand on that
broken mirror where is she
say it dude say what
say you don't know whether or not this
is the real me or just a reflection in
the mirror
really
okay I don't know whether the you I'm
holding on to is really you for the
reflection or a reflection in the mirror
almost to it she's on the before boards
by the intross
oh I win detective
you I told you but I mean the mirror
told you but but you know
oh
[Music]